ein land feiert brandenburger tor berlin
heute abend der ort die stadt ihre
menschen geteilt durch eine mauer
bis zu dieser nacht vor genau 30 jahren
als sich ost und west hier in den armen
lagen
[Musik]
ein emotionaler moment der bis heute
wirkt politiker staatsgäste und
zigtausende bürger erinnern an eine
nacht die geschichte schrieb
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein an
diesem 9
november zu den heute -nachrichten wir
haben die welt im blick den sport
natürlich auch mit kristin guten abend
aber wir beginnen in berlin heute wo
dieses land zurück blickt auf einen
besonderen moment seiner geschichte
neunter november vor 30 jahren 1989 die
berliner mauer trennt nicht mehr
es sind viele gäste da staatsoberhäupter
aus den nachbarländern es gibt eine
gedenkfeier und eine große party und
worte des bundespräsidenten der diesen
tag so beschreibt die mauer sie fiel ja
nicht einfach die friedlichen
revolutionäre haben sie eingerissen sie
die mutigen in der ddr haben geschichte
geschrieben
frank walter steinmeier erinnert an die
zitat nacht der nächte nach der nichts
mehr so war wie zuvor
und er wünscht sich erzählen wir
einander unsere geschichten vor allem
hören wir einander zu und nehmen wir uns
gegenseitig ernst aus berlin berichten
markus gross und romanesco war
grosse feste auf großer bühne so feiert
berlin 30 jahre friedliche revolution
der neunter november 89 ein tag des
jubels und 30 jahre danach das land
vereinigt aber womöglich mit neuen
mauern in den köpfen die neuen mauern in
unserem land die haben wir selbst gebaut
und nur wir selber können sie einreißen
also schauen wir nicht zu schlagen wir
nicht darüber reißen wir diese mauern
endlich ein meine damen und herren die
die die freiheit in osteuropa erkämpft
haben sind heute auch mit dabei
die staatschefs aus ungarn tschechien
polen und der slowakei
beginn der feierlichkeiten am vormittag
an der mauergedenkstätte bernauer straße
der neunte november sei ein
schicksalstag der deutschen die
bundeskanzlerin erinnert an den
mauerfall und an die pogromnacht 1938
november in dem sich in besonderer weise
sowohl die fürchterlichen als auch die
glücklichen momente unserer geschichte
widerspiegeln
er mahnt uns dass wir hass rassismus und
antisemitismus entschlossen
entgegentreten müssen an den mauerfall
erinnert berlin schon die ganze woche
unter anderem an den orten der
revolution videoinstallationen am
alexanderplatz der friedliche protest
vom november 89
ein highlight auch der fliegende teppich
mit 30.000 botschaften wünschen und
hoffnungen
30 jahre nach dem mauerfall die einheits
bilanz zwiespältig also ich glaube dass
noch viel zu tun wir haben in vielen
dingen insbesondere unsere freunde aus
ostdeutschland nicht so mitgenommen wie
man das hätte machen müssen
ich bin ausdrücklich für mich nicht
abgehängt für mich ist alles ganz
wunderbar gelaufen und ich denke wir
sollten jetzt nach vorne schauen
ich komme aus mecklenburg vorpommern wir
haben eine andere mentalität als die
sachsen und die schleswig holsteiner
genauso
wie die bayern es ist ein tag der groß
gefeiert wird ein tag der freude aber in
der rückbesinnung auch ein tag der
nachdenklichkeit und antje pieper ist
für uns in berlin haben wir
brandenburger tor antje guten abend
kannst du mal ein bisschen die stimmung
im moment beschreiben ist wie viele es
davon party und wie viel festlicher
rückblick es ist beides diese besondere
jahrestag wird natürlich gefeiert zum
einen musik gerade spielt die
staatskapelle berlin unter der leitung
von
[Musik]
und es gibt
nachdenkliche töne es kommen zeitzeugen
zu wort und bürgerrechtler von damals
und heute bin ich jetzt gefeiert und
demokratie einsetzen
jetzt ist das ja ein besonderer ort vor
30 jahren hätte niemand gedacht dass man
da mal durch flanieren würde können
wie will denn berlin diese nacht noch
feiern also das große finale ist so ab
20 uhr mit einem feuerwerk geben an
diesem symbolträchtigen ort im
brandenburger tor und dann gibt es ja
auch noch eine after show party mit dj
westbam
also ich denke mal das wird noch mal
richtig lange nacht in berlin an tpv
live aus berlin herzlichen dank da
gucken wir jetzt zurück in diesem moment
vor dreißig jahren fielen auf einer
pressekonferenz in ost-berlin beinahe
beiläufig worte die enorme folgen hatten
die mauer die unüberwindbar schienen und
an der viele menschen ihr leben gelassen
hatten begann zu wanken
am ende dieser nacht tanzten die
berliner auf ihr und feierten das ende
der teilung ihrer stadt schwerin ak nach
blick zurück auf die entscheidenden
augenblicke
die nacht der nächte voller jubel und
freude am berliner kudamm feiern
tausende irgendwo in der menge auch eine
mutter und tochter aus ostberlin das
glück beginnt mit einem versehen auf der
ost berliner pressekonferenz 18 uhr 57
verkündet polizeisprecher schabowski
beiläufig bürger dürften ins ausland
reisen
nachfragen der presse das gilt ab wann
übersehen die sperrfrist vier uhr
morgens der anfang vom ende der ddr
schon 19 14 meldet die heute -sendung
reisefreiheit
tausende strömen zu den grenzübergängen
an der wanheimer straße explosive
stimmung
die ddr regierung ist abgetaucht die
grenze haben nur die anweisung bürger zu
vertrösten
bei dem ansturm dürfen die ersten in den
westen aber sind per stempel im ausweis
ausgebootet 23 29 kapitulieren die
grenze der schlagbaum offen keine
kontrollen mehr
roter teppich fürs volk in diesen
stunden ist helmut kohl auf staatsbesuch
in polen ost und west berliner erobern
am brandenburger tor die mauer tanzen
vereint
wir hätten hier angedachte den vier
wochen das war hier mal drauf stehen
heute ab mitternacht ein letztes
aufbäumen der armee für soldaten gilt
erhöhte gefechtsbereitschaft da sind die
bilder längst in aller welt
30 jahre später treffen wir sehr bringer
bern ruft die junge frau von damals noch
einmal auf dem kudamm der mauerfall sei
das beste was ihr passiert ist
in jener nacht wird geschichte
geschrieben
und die deutschen sind das glücklichste
volk der nimmt auch an anderen orten
entlang der ehemaligen grenze wird heute
gefeiert wie in mödlareuth das dorf
liegt direkt auf der grenze von
thüringen und bayern und war durch die
mauer getrennt
heute von dort dutzende trabis und co
durch ein nachgebautes grenztor um den
mauerfall zu begehen zu feiern
tatsächlich öffnete sich der
grenzübergang in mödlareuth erst einen
monat nach dem fall der mauer am 9
dezember dann wollen die bewohner noch
mal ihre einheit feiern
mehr zu diesem großen thema natürlich
auf heute.de und außerdem gibt es dort
den genauen zeitlichen ablauf der
geschehnisse am 9 november 89 in einem
live blog der neunter november ein
denkwürdiger tag in der deutschen
geschichte also darauf weist der
vorsitzende des zentralrats der juden in
deutschland hin josef schuster
er könne nachvollziehen dass der
dreißigsten jahrestag des mauerfalls
eine besondere bedeutung einnehmen
man dürfe arbeiten nicht die
geschehnisse 1938 vergessen sagte
schuster der nordwest-zeitung
nazi-schergen hatten synagogen jüdische
geschäfte und wohnungen in brand
gesteckt und jüdische bürger ermordet
die pogromnacht habe jedem deutlich
gemacht in welche richtung sich der
nationalsozialismus entwickelt
und jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten
von heute die energiewende steht und
fällt mit der windenergie aber die
hersteller von windkraftanlagen stecken
in der krise der größte hersteller die
firma enercon will jetzt 3000 stellen
streichen
der grund immer weniger windräder werden
aufgestellt genehmigungsverfahren dauern
oft jahre bürger klagen
dabei ist der strom aus wind elementar
für deutschlands klimaschutzziele
um sie zu erreichen müssten jedes jahr
4500 megawatt windenergie neu ins netz
kommt dieses jahr werden es wohl nur
knapp 500 anna-maria schock berichtet
bilder wie diese wird es hier in aurich
künftig wohl kaum noch geben bei enercon
deutschlands größter hersteller von
windenergieanlagen leidet unter dem ende
des booms und streicht massiv stellen
eine nachricht die die mitarbeiter
gestern kalt erwischt hat wir malen
schock wichtig gerade passiert ist sind
alle sehr enttäuscht richtig wir haben
vielleicht noch drücken können zur
ausbildung fertig machen
die ganze deutsche windenergie branche
steckt in der krise
schuld daran sei die politik der
bundesregierung sagt die enercon
geschäftsführung die aktuelle energie
und klimapolitik gefährdet nicht nur
über jahre aufgebautes know how und
arbeitsplätze in unserer branche sondern
auch den klimaschutz und die
energiewende insgesamt
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium erklärt
dazu auf zdf anfrage
man verfolge die situation genau die
stärkung der windenergie an land sei
aber eine gemeinschaftsaufgabe von bund
und ländern
tatsächlich ist die zahl neuer windräder
an land seit dem vergangenen jahr
dramatisch eingebrochen
in diesem jahr sind gerade mal 150 neu
aufgestellt wurden lange
genehmigungsverfahren viele klagen von
bürgerinitiativen zu wenig flächen auf
denen windräder tatsächlich gebaut
werden dürfen
die liste der gründe ist lang nicht
leicht für die wind branche die politik
muss dringend gegensteuern es gab ja
auch ein wind gipfel jetzt muss es darum
gehen dieser branche zu helfen im
klimapaket werden zwei richtige ziele
formuliert aber die schritte dorthin
reichen nicht aus es muss dringend
korrigiert werden
bis 2030 soll der strom in deutschland
zu 65 prozent aus erneuerbarer energie
stammen
ein ziel das zu diesem zeitpunkt
unerreichbar scheint im streit um das
atom abkommen mit dem iran stehen die
zeichen weiter auf eskalation jetzt hat
die iranische führung die anreicherung
von uran in der atomanlage fordo wieder
aufgenommen
laut experten soll das druck machen auf
deutschland und andere vertragspartner
hintergrund ist dass die usa aus dem
atom abkommen einseitig ausgestiegen
waren und wirtschaftssanktionen verhängt
hatten
nach und eineinhalb jahren im gefängnis
ist brasiliens ex-präsident luiz inácio
lula da silva wieder frei zumindest
vorläufig und sofort kündigte er an er
wolle erneut in die politik einsteigen
der oberste gerichtshof hatte
entschieden dass straftäter erst nach
ausschöpfung aller rechtsmittel in haft
müssen
lula war im vergangenen jahr in zweiter
instanz wegen korruption und geldwäsche
zu acht jahren haft verurteilt worden
er kann das urteil aber noch einmal
anfechten
spanien wählt morgen ein neues parlament
schon wieder muss man sagen denn es ist
das vierte mal in nicht einmal vier
jahren
der grund es gibt keine klaren
mehrheiten im parlament bei der letzten
wahl im april lagen links und rechts
parteien fast gleichauf premierminister
pedro sanchez und seine
sozialdemokratische pässe hatten zwar
die nase vorn für eine stabile regierung
hätten sie aber koalitionspartner aus
den reihen der linken gebraucht doch da
gab es streit stadtreinigung eine
pattsituation von der jetzt die anderen
profitieren könnten thomas walde
bei der jährlichen prozession für die
schutzheilige madrids heute mittag
hofften einige teilnehmer auf ein wunder
das wunder dass sie bald wieder eine
handlungsfähige regierung haben brauchen
eine regierung egal ob es eine rechte
oder eine linke regierung wird
hauptsache eine regierung gestern abend
schlossen die parteien den kampf um
stimmen ab ministerpräsident pedro
sanchez hat das symbolträchtig in
barcelona seine sozialisten wollten gern
soziale themen in den vordergrund
stellen
aber die krise in katalonien
überschattet alles nicht der ist der
stärkste der am lautesten schreit
sondern der der den hass überwindet und
die vernunft durchsetzt
barcelona wird von unruhen erschüttert
seit die anführer der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung zu langen
haftstrafen verurteilt wurden
am lautesten hat aber die extreme rechte
vox die regierung attackiert sie
verteidige die spanische einheit nicht
laut umfragen profitiert vox von der
krise hier werden starke stimmengewinne
vorausgesagt
das ist ein nationaler notstand weil es
eine rebellion gibt durch eine regionale
regierung von umstürzen wir sagen diese
krise erfordert drastischere maßnahmen
die politischen lager stehen sich
unversöhnlich gegenüber auch die
konservative partei kündigt an nicht
über ihren schatten springen zu wollen
unsere partei wird auf keinen fall pedro
sanchez zu einer weiteren amtszeit
verhelfen
so droht spanien bereits das nächste
part wenn ich doch noch ein kleines
wunder geschieht es ist ein gigantischer
feuer streifen in australien die
buschbrände dort wütenden zwischen einem
rund 1000 kilometer lange gebiet entlang
der ostküste
mindestens drei menschen kamen ums leben
mehr als 150 häuser sind zerstört und
der wetterbericht verheißt nichts gutes
es soll trocken und windig bleiben und
damit sind wir in dieser sendung beim
samstags sport und bei dir christina
auch gleich mal rein in die bundesliga
schlussstrich beim ersten fc köln
der 1 2 niederlage gegen hoffenheim
trennte sich der tabellenvorletzte
zuerst von sportchef armin veh und
beurlaubt inzwischen auch noch trainer
achim beierlorzer zwingender umbruch bei
den geißböcken die allgemeine situation
passend zum motto des clubs gestern
abend erst der sportdirektor heute
morgen der trainer die horrorbilanz von
achim beierlorzer elf spiele sieben
zähler
wir haben jetzt ein punkt erreicht wo
wir der meinung waren dass wir einen
neuen impuls brauchen bayern ort sein
weiteres teures missverständnis erst im
sommer für 700.000 euro ablöse aus
regensburg gekommen
köln muss sich nun neu aufstellen nicht
spürbar anders sondern vor allem besser
dann schauen wir auf die heutigen
ergebnisse des elften spieltages eher
beleibt sich weiter in der erfolgsspur 4
2 bei hertha bsc auf schalke erkämpfte
düsseldorf 1 3 zu 3 mainz verschärft die
krise 2 zu 3 gegen aufsteiger union
berlin paderborn unterliegt augsburg 0
zu 1 der gipfel läuft in münchen morgen
drei sonntagsspiele mit dem aktuellen
tabellenführer gladbach gegen bremen
hinter dem spitzenreiter vorläufig
leipzig auf platz 2 hoffenheim hoch auf
3 und schalke auf 5 aber in der oberen
hälfte kann sich noch einiges
verschieben unten verbessert sich union
berlin auf 11 vor die härter hinter
düsseldorf und augsburg stürzt mainz
runter auf den relegationsplatz köln und
paderborn unverändert die schlusslichter
und in allen bundesliga-stadien wird an
diesem wochenende an den früheren
nationaltorwart robert enke erinnert
denn morgen vor genau zehn jahren hatte
sich der damals 32-jährige in hannover
das leben genommen schwer erkrankt an
depressionen
was nur ganz wenige wussten seitdem
kämpft seine witwe teresa um den offenen
umgang mit dieser krankheit und alles
zum topspiel bayern bvb ausführlich im
aktuellen sportstudio 23 uhr zu gast bei
sven voss schalkes trainer david wagner
erste medaille und zwar gold für die
deutschen behinderten leichtathleten bei
den para weltmeisterschaften in dubai im
200 meter lauf der unterschenkel
amputierten bei ihrem garten
aus leverkusen in 26 93 sekunden die
schnellste
ich war überrascht als wir die
deutschland fahne in die hand gedrückt
wurde sagte die 28 jährige überglücklich
boxen live im zweiten nach neun jahren
ist es wieder soweit heute abend nur 25
meldet sich zdf sportextra live aus
hamburg mit dem hauptkampf im
superleichtgewicht mit atem halten dem
olympischen bronzemedaillengewinner von
2016 der vor heimischer kulisse in
seinem achten profikampf auf den russen
islam duman of thrift die anderen kämpfe
gibt es bereits ab 21 30 live in der zdf
mediathek danke christin dann gucken wir
jetzt nochmal direkt nach berlin zu den
feiern 30 jahre mauerfall das sind die
aktuellen höhepunkte laut lichtshow gute
laune und gleich nach uns überträgt das
zdf weiter die große feier am
brandenburger tor noch bis 20 uhr 15
das wetter übrigens in berlin heute so
wie vor 30 jahren morgen aber bringt
hoch paloma ruhiges novemberwetter und
alle details dazu hat gleich katja
honnefer ich empfehle ihnen das heute
journal mit dem kollegen claus kleber 22
uhr 45 und morgen sind wir wieder für
sie dar um punkt sieben bis dann danke
fürs zu sehen an diesem besonderen tag
und in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genommen meine damen und herren über dem
mittelmeer zogen unwetter über den
pyrenäen fällt schnee und großbritannien
meldet uns überschwemmungen nur bei uns
in mitteleuropa da wird das ein ganz
ruhiger sonntag dank des hochs paloma
denn das lenkt alle regenwolken um sich
herum nur an der nordseeküste da klappt
das mit dem herum lenken nicht so ganz
da gibt es morgen einige regenschauer so
ein hoch im november bedeutet aber oft
auch nebel denn die nächte sind ja schon
so lang dass sie ordentlich auskühlen
können in dieser nacht gibt es doch ganz
verbreitet frost zumindest am boden und
am alpenrand wird sehr kalt mit minus 7
grad frostfrei bleibt es einzig an den
küsten von nord- und ostsee zu bindet
sich oft nebel und es kann gefährlich
glatt seien auf den straßen vor allen
dingen auf brücken und in waldstücken
und dieser zäher nebel der kann sich
dann morgen lange halten vor allen
dingen in den flusstälern
süddeutschlands und erneut sie gibt es
einige regenschauer und das ändert sich
auch am nachmittag nicht dafür lösen
sich hoffentlich die nebelfelder in
süddeutschland auf klappt das nicht dann
bleibt es kalt dann steigen die
temperaturen kaum auf 4 bis 6 grad sonst
sind es sieben bis zehn grad
ruhig beginnt die neue woche dann wird
es von tag zu tag kälter und es gibt
auch wieder neuschnee
schönen abend noch